people would rather claim that body fat
has no bearing on health and mortality
outcomes to avoid making overweight
people feel upset even if this causes
them to literally die sooner or have a
worse quality of life over the long run
parents would rather allow children to
play computer games and access social
media every night instead of dealing
with the discomfort of taking it away
from them even if it ruins their brain
development social skills and
self-esteem toxic compassion is the
prioritization of shortterm emotional
Comfort over everything else over truth
reality actual long-term outcomes it
optimizes for Lu good rather than doing
good Elon Musk recently responded to
some criticism about his political
alignment and contribution to climate
change and skepticism of it I think and
then he identified how big of a shift
Tesla had caused in the electric vehicle
market and the downstream impact of that
on the environment he said he's done
more for the climate than any other
human in history and this quote from him
is what I care about is the reality of
goodness not the perception of it and
what I see all over the place is people
who care about looking good while doing
evil